bloody battered and bruised but still
alive anti-government protester Dimitri
Belikov was kidnapped and tortured for a
week before being dumped in a forest
he's recovering in a private hospital
here but he's covered in cuts and
bruises I never spoke you I have my
hands pierced
they've crucified me he says they've cut
off my ear cut my face all my body is
beaten black and blue the police are
investigating but the protesters believe
the security forces are behind this and
at least two other abductions many more
are being held by the police after the
two sides clash last week the
international community is calling for
restraint as well as an investigation
into the claims of kidnap and torture
we're appalled by the deaths reported in
recent days in Kiev which should be
promptly thoroughly and independently
investigated we're also calling for an
investigation into reports of
kidnappings and torture
despite the freezing cold temperatures
thousands of protestors remain in their
camps holding the Maidan or freedom
square in central Kiev negotiations are
taking place to find a way forward but
these people want the President to stand
down
he won't though although he's apparently
ill President Yanukovych has agreed the
repeal of anti-protest legislation he's
also signed into law an amnesty for
protestors are being held by the police
but it's dependent upon these protest
groups leaving buildings that they
currently hold and they say they're not
going to do that so we're back in a sort
of impasse
more worryingly for these people is that
the military have now written to the
president saying that he needs to solve
this situation they don't know whether
they're softening their position or
whether they're wanting to come into
this camp and smash it up if that
happens the protest groups have promised
to fight back guaranteeing more
bloodshed two sides are at loggerheads
so far there seems little chance of any
negotiated end to this anytime soon mr.
Ramsay Sky News Kiev